trail est avec nous sachez que c'est une
exclusivité mondiale puisque vous avez
refusé de faire toutes les autres télés
pour être dans tpm paix ce soir donc
c'est une exclusivité sur ses beats en
direct d'une gueule jessica merci d'être
avec nous avec plaisir alors c'est
énorme parce que vous êtes venus pour
votre livre
jessica non c'est tout moi voilà
j'essaie cativen et c'est une
exclusivité pour tpm p moi j'étais
vraiment j'étais sur le cul quoi ça je
te dis jessica et je pense que beaucoup
de monde
non mais je vous raconte la blague c'est
parce que depuis ce matin tout le monde
nous dit jessica ne veut faire que tpm
paie quoi vraiment donc c'est une
exclusivité mondiale donc merci à vous
je suis pas
[Applaudissements]
je suis là on va parler votre libre
j'aimerais vous poser que des questions
très simples
tout d'abord j'aimerais vous parler de
l'écriture pour vous écrire est ce que
c'est une chose sporadiques ou bien à
ses cadences et pour vous bien pour moi
c'est une horreur d'écrire
j'adore formuler des phrases tout ça
mais c'est vrai que écrire je défende à
tous les maux clairement je t'avoue je
laisse une calèche l'enlever degré de
jessica alors on t'a connu dans les bars
et ses sacs excusé dans les marseillais
le sujet pas du tout suivi de mort si je
regarde jamais le brésil mais j'ai été
un peu partout et puis avec mes
collègues et voilà comment tu fais quoi
la base au fait à la base cette [ __ ]
de musique perçu oui j'étais coiffeuse à
l'ansa adacore ouais bah si je cite
était déjà venu nous voir et après tu es
tu as été montré dans mercier comment
parce que j'ai été casté est tout
simplement mais j'étais en coupe et
julien à l'époque il faisait déjà de la
télé donc c'est ça était peu avec lui
maintenant
ah non non non non non le pr non non non
non non non non non et donc tu étais
dans les mares si les marseillais en
fait c'est des gens qui viennent de
marseille et qui vont en voyage grâce à
la production pour faire des voyages et
pour ce fait chaud en fait c'est ça il
ya un peu de paix chaud mais pas que
pour ça mais en fait c'est quoi le but
des marseillais j'ai jamais compris
cette émission les marchés tout
simplement un groupe qui part à
l'étranger et on a des jobs est tout
simplement que la boucle luton et il
faut réussir ces deux j'avais sur les
racks ben on retourne en france quoi
d'accord c'était de la faune alors pour
livre c'est tout moi alors c'est mieux
qu'il écrit vraiment oui je l'écris avec
une personne évidemment parce que moi il
faut que la ponctuation c'est pas fait
pour moi d'accord ouais donc voilà je
vous racontais là on est vraiment et ça
me tenait à coeur de raconter ma vie est
de savoir que les gens sachent devient
quoi les parents qui tiennent alors
quelques motifs et turbulente c'est ce
que tu dis parce que moi je lis que ce
qu'il ya derrière et habiter dans une
caravane
oui c'est arrivé j'habitais dans une
caravane jusqu'à mes 6 ans away est à
cran s'est posée mais oui j'ai grandi en
caravane je suis pas né avec une
cuillère en or dans la bouche comme les
gens peuvent penser donc est aujourd'hui
t'as combien de tableau mais il faut le
voir sur un store trois millions sept
premiers sets et aujourd'hui tu vis de
ça le thé poste de t2 je vis de mes
business que j'ai montée j'ai des
sociétés gm parfum j'ai plein de chasse
des parents sont fiers de toi
aujourd'hui je pense qu'ils sont très
fiers de moi c'est vraiment ah ouais
oui oui il y aura huit mois j'ai vu le
lit
alors effectivement c'est pas la grande
littérature mais ce n'est pas ce qu'on
recherche quand on lit le livre moi je
note que c'est très sincère c'est très
juste et très honnête très honnête
vraiment en entend votre voix alors il
ya des maladresses mais moi j'ai bien
aimé il ya des zones dont vous venez
vite et pas les sujets vous parlez
beaucoup d'alliés aussi des femmes
battues et je trouve qu'il y avait
vraiment des idées très joli moment et
je pense que pour les fans de jessica
servir idéalement fait jessica vous
m'avez dit doug maybee vous laisser vous
fait l'apologie de la chirurgie
esthétique vous et vous avez dit on
arrive on me dit tu as vu j'ai refait
tout est tour à tour tape et assume
totalement
ouais ça se voit donc carrément donné je
vais pas dire c'est pas vrai non mais
c'est très bien fait franchement il est
muet après du coup non franchement c'est
très bien fait que la tare fait quoi en
fait eu le nez le menton
alors le menton et mieux que celui des
bogdanov et donc ouais t'as fait le nez
le menton
j'ai fait des objections d'état erreurs
mais j'ai vais avoir 30 ans hall a
raison de faire ça comme moi un mets toi
tu as besoin
[Applaudissements]
comme on sait si tard parce que pour
tous les jeunes qui nous regardaient ce
que est ce que tu penses que c'est pas
un mauvais exemple de donner voilà cet
exemple de faire beaucoup de chirurgie
esthétique ya plein de jeunes filles
pour qui tu es un exemple
toi tu dis voilà tu dis voilà moi je le
fais parce que je me sens mieux dans ma
peau mais elles ne sont pas obligées de
le faire et de faire comme toi quoi non
bien sûr je laisse clairement lié bien
décidé à des opérations le montant gelé
très très mal vécu j'ai failli partir en
dépression et joyeux mais tout enlever
ouais j'ai très mal vécu au début mais
je conseille pas du tout faire la
chirurgie esthétique au jeune fille moi
je le fais j'ai 30 ans ça y est
maintenant mais j'ai pris dans le
routier sika avant une photo de jessica
avant et aujourd'hui donc tu as fait le
menton et sinon tu as fais d'autres
choses
j'ai la gironde et les pompiers la
bouche parce qu'on a des massacres et à
west avait la bouche très gonflé en fait
à sézanne voile avait une bombe à un
moment c'est un média voilà alors donc
ça c'est tout avant way est bas alors
t'es tu te fais pas y'a pas un gros
changement jeunesse et tous les jets à
chaque fois vrai mais ça alors la
chirurgie esthétique
si vous voulez savoir si c'est bien fait
il faut pas que ça se remarque
affronteront un maillot pas non mais
c'est vrai voilà maintenant que ça se
voit quand même aux transports on en
fait quoi
oui mais où donc ça sert à rien d'en
faire mais bon voilà et indélicat c'est
délicat
non mais c'est bête c'est parce que je
me vois tout à la télé j'ai toujours mon
retour j'ai les commentaires sont des
gens puisque malgré tout bas les gens et
de clash sur ton physique et puise yvan
fort ouais et du coup mais finalement il
finit par remarquer les défauts et puis
ça te perturbe les limites je pense qu'à
ça et quand je me voyais profile dans
moi je me vois pas évidemment dans le
miroir moment dont je me dérangeait pas
mais vrai profil quand j'avais mon
retour d'image
oui je me sais j'en ai parlé ou alors tu
avais pas de manteau tout à fait
rajouter un menton voilà j'ai mis en
boucle atik pajot benjamin castaldi et
fait pareil avec qui on l'assumé c'est
bien sûr la charge de nettoyer pas de
problème avec ça
non mais c'est vrai j'ai fait
liposuccion je disais pas de vous avez
fait qu'une hypothèse une liposuccion
j'ai fait j'ai refait un peu les dents
aussi bien voilà je pense - effet les
dons le menton le nez les pommettes non
pas les pour mettre dans leur moi ça non
d'accord la poitrine ah oui d'accord et
le fessier le fessier puisque les
actionnaires voteront pas encore le
physique c'est en projet non mais c'est
george l enfant que j'éclate que je
ressens plus rien oui je retape reccord
jeux ludiques l'air d'accord vous en
êtes aujourd'hui le sentimental ans que
c'est la servane d'un soir je suis marié
je suis très d'accord vous allez avoir
un enfant bientôt j'espère parce que je
peux le circoncire
[Rires]
c'est injuste qui caquettent avec
bouteille content d'être avec mme
jessica montador vraiment moi c'est
contador qu'est ce qui va se passer dans
les marseillais la prochaine saison la
pn chose que les problèmes qu elle des
problèmes souvent c'est une saison avec
vous êtes une fune bourg de problème là
il va se passer quoi gens non peine
choses et coupe des séparations des
histoires ça se passe où là il vous a
mené ou à temps on a faim on est partis
direction l'asie mais on est parti en
chine au vietnam on a dit on et ouais je
suis aussi un petit peu partout asie
chine vietnam tout seul c'était génial
je parle non à la voie d'accord vous
êtes parti partout en fait cette coupe
voyage un voyage est payé pour faire
c'est que ces conneries
oui c'est vrai vous êtes payés on peut
savoir à peu près que mauvaise payez
vous faire cesser non je peux pas le
dire se débarrasser vélo me faut un show
je peux le savoir 1 c'est un coup de fil
je le souhaite tout de suite 1 le russe
est une des plus connues donc elle peut
négocier quoi dragan mrda combien sont
payés à peu près alors les cachets
production c'est entre oui ça doit être
ça entre dix et vingt mille suivant le
candidat pour toute la saison
oui prépa saison d'accord on va très
bien disait voilà nom du couple non non
non c'est moi quoi c - oui nature oui
spes demi tout va non non c'est moi que
c'est moins que dix ou vingt mille pour
toute la saison
ça dépend des candidats oui mais vous
par exemple moi c'est
c'est plus que ce que 20000 non si je
veux le savoir 1 c'est là je vous dis
faut arrêter de mumbai et ça devrait
vite réalité je dis rien c'est l'om
groupe que moi c'est la même production
chez un coup de fil à passer j'ai ton
contrat demain donc aux mélodies donc à
genève au mieux tu dis la vérité
maintenant sinon je vais à savoir demain
ça va tout un bordel pas possible ce
n'est pas loin de dire ah bon vous le
diront confidentielles ah oui bon on va
pas simple du coup tu pendant la pub
vous seront sera tout ça vous inquiétez
pas maga libérés au bout de dix ans vous
ben moi je suis sûre entre 10 et 20
d'accord mais c'est souvent les
candidats d'anciens de votre nouveau et
c'est là qu'ils gagnent 200 euros par
jour c'est pour deux qui sont à cinq et
six semaines de tournage d'accord 8e
calculé en jour 1c 200 à 500 euros par
jour pour aller franchement pour aller
voyager sa pimpante à un tour du monde
ça ouais bah c'est sympa on fait le tour
de monde non plus on donne ce travail
s'est dit heureux dans les filières du
travail c'est là quoi mettre des morts
au fil des maillots
memories
gens qui travaillent vraiment dans ce
cas là mais la maison leur sofa attend
ses 108 ans qui est ce que c'est vrai
que ça vous fait même perdre de l'argent
par rapport à vos partenariats qu'ils
vous empêche de les faire un voyage dan
travaille bien mais je vous jure il ya
des heures j'en fais pas la grasse mat
on doit être toujours présent
c'est comme du cinéma souvent la
pastèque
voilà c'était que ça pas d'histoire mais
s'amuse moi j'adore les gens qui sont
dedans mais j'ai jamais regardé jarrier
j'ai jamais regarder ses émissions mais
je trouve moi c'est franchement je
l'aurais fait je l'aurais pris jour elle
peut le faire ouais sida effet le
tunisien à miami
[Rires]